President Trump now says congressional
Democrats had better stop investigating
his presidency he abruptly cut off a
White House meeting with House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi and Senate Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer yesterday the
president says he was upset that Pelosi
accused him of a cover-up Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning
good morning you know by the president's
own admission it was that term cover-up
that set him off and led to his
ultimatum either Democrats dropped their
investigations of him or he won't work
with them even on issues he cares about
yet these phony investigations over with
the president viewed his walkout as a
power play speaker Pelosi called it a
temper tantrum I pray for the President
of the United States and I pray for the
United States of America to watch what
happened in the White House would make
your jaw drop their standoff put a stake
in what was one of their few areas of
common ground
I told Senator Schumer
speaker Pelosi I want to do
infrastructure you can't do it under
these circumstances White House sources
tell CBS News that President Trump an
avid cable news watcher exploded after
he saw Pelosi say this just before their
meeting we believe that the President of
the United States is engaged in a
cover-up President Trump walked into the
meeting with a dozen Democratic leaders
and walked out again three minutes later
I don't do cover-ups slamming their
investigations at a hastily called Rose
Garden press conference when I went to
Wisconsin and Michigan and Pennsylvania
I don't say oh let's call Russia maybe
they get it's a hoax
both Pelosi and mr. Trump see benefits
to their tough talk low C gets points
with increasingly restless liberal
members I think it should be engaged his
campaign chairman is in prison don't
tell me there's not enough to debate
here and mr. Trump's aides say he feels
punching back is a good reelection
strategy the i-word can you imagine
President Trump is shooting back at
Pelosi 'he's claimed that he had a
temper tantrum on twitter he said that
he was quote personally very polite and
calm during the meeting Democrats argue
that the real reason he walked out
Anthony is because he knows that the
issue they were discussing
infrastructure is a tough one for him
and that he can't sell that two trillion
dollar package they say to his own party
dude they're very different impressions
of that meeting Nancy thank you very
much